bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre en direct de l'hémicycle la
séance de questions cribles thématiques
elle est consacrée aujourd'hui à
l'aggravation des inégalités sociales
dans le système scolaire c'est luc
chatel ministre de l'éducation qui vient
répondre aux questions des sénateurs au
coeur des débats les résultats de la
france aux tests pisa
le programme international pour le suivi
des acquis des élèves
il s'agit d'une étude internationale qui
évalue le niveau de connaissance moyen
des élèves de 15 ans et la france est
loin d'être en tête de ce classement
alors que c'est un des pays de l' ocde
qui consacrent le plus d'argent par
élève
je vous propose donc tout de suite de
prendre la direction de l'hémicycle très
bonne séance à tous la parole sur cool
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues ma question portera sur les
projets de réussite éducative
je rappelle que cpr eux sont la
déclinaison concrète et opérationnelle
au niveau local du programme réussite
éducative
issu de la loi de cohésion sociale de
janvier 2005
il s'adresse aux enfants et adolescents
qui présentent des signes de fragilité
ou ne bénéficient pas d'un environnement
social familial et culturel favorable à
leur développement
ce programme trop méconnu me semble
constituer un élément fondamental de la
lutte contre les inégalités sociales
dans le système scolaire
il témoigne d'une nouvelle approche dans
la prise en compte des jeunes élèves les
plus en difficulté et vient compléter
les autres dispositifs éducatifs
ces projets favorisent l'épanouissement
de l'enfant sa socialisation son
autonomisation et participe ainsi à sa
réussite scolaire
de nombreuses collectivités locales se
sont engagées dans ce processus car
elles ont indéniablement un rôle
essentiel à jouer dans la mise en place
d'une vérité et d'une véritable
politique local d'éducation
il faut se réjouir que depuis cinq ans
de nombreux projets se soit développée
et fait leurs preuves
et obtenu la reconnaissance des acteurs
de la vie éducative conseils généraux
ministre de l'éducation collectivités
l'ecc local école parents cependant
alors même que la crise se fait de plus
en plus sentir sur une population qui se
paupérise littéralement il semble que
depuis plusieurs mois les moyens alloués
à ces projets se réduisent comme peau de
chagrin
certains projets ont vu leurs
financements baissé de plus de 35 % en
2010 et de 20% peut-être pour 2011
à ce rythme que restera-t-il de cette
dynamique si positive prendre les
problématiques des enfants et de leurs
parents de manière individuelle a prouvé
son efficacité dans la lutte contre les
inégalités sociales et l'échec scolaire
c'est pourquoi je vous demande de
renforcer ce dispositif en lui donnant
les moyens de son ambition
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous vous
engagez sur le devenir des projets de
réussite éducative et leur pérennisation
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur luc chatel ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
de la vie associative
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur laborde
vous avez raison de rappeler
l'importance des programmes de réussite
éducative qui ont un intérêt majeur
c'est qu'ils prennent en charge les
élèves les adolescents de manière
globale c'est-à-dire pas uniquement sur
l'aspect éducatif mais aussi l'ouverture
culturelle sportive la prise en charge
en matière de santé l'accompagnement
social
la parenté et donc c'est un programme
intéressant à ce titre depuis mon
arrivée au ministère l'éducation
nationale j'ai veillé à ce que ce
programme s'articule bien avec d'autres
dispositifs dont nous avons nous
éducation nationale la charge directe
je rappelle que programme de rééducation
de réviser cats iv placé sous l'autorité
de l'axé dans le cadre de la politique
de la ville et bien je veille à ce qu'il
y ait une bonne articulation notamment
vis-à-vis de l'accompagnement éducatif
dispositif que nous avons instaurée au
collège en 2008 et qui vise à accueillir
après 16 heures
les jeunes qui s'étaient laissé jusqu'à
présent à eux mêmes et qui sont pris en
charge à 62% pour de l'aide aux devoirs
à 22% pour de l'aide dans le domaine des
arts ou de la culture ou encore pour un
accompagnement sportif à hauteur de 16%
nous avons décidé avec mes collègues
notamment le ministre de la ville
d'avoir une répartition claire du rôle
de chacun c'est à dire que l'éducation
nationale est bien là pour transmettre
les savoirs et donc assure
l'accompagnement personnalisé la partie
éducative de soutien scolaire très
importante dans la politique de
personnalisation que nous menons la
politique de la ville à travers les pme
complète l'action de l'école hors temps
scolaire notamment en orientant les
jeunes en difficulté vers tous les
dispositifs qui existent en la matière
et puis enfin les collectivités
territoriales elle doit mettre à
disposition les ressources locales
existantes de nature à faciliter le bon
déroulement de l'ensemble de ses actions
mon collègue maurice leroy a récemment
rappelé que les programme de réussite
éducative méritait d'être étoffé et donc
nous voulons fixer de nouvelles
priorités dans le domaine de la santé
dans le domaine de l'absentéisme et du
décrochage scolaire de l'accompagnement
individuel mais aussi la prise en charge
des élèves qui peuvent être
temporairement exclus de l'école du
soutien à la parentalité ou pour
améliorer les relations entre les
parents et l'école
c'est donc tout l'enjeu des
renégociations des contrats urbains de
cohésion sociale dans laquelle
l'éducation nationale prendra toute sa
part et c'est un point sur lequel je
veillerai particulièrement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai bien entendu votre réponse
et je voulais simplement vous dire que
la gt ma question j'étais un petit peu
plus
j'allais dire basique je ne pensais pas
seulement à culture sport et
accompagnement aux devoirs je pensais
vraiment à la santé et à ce qui fait le
quotidien des enfants et leurs parents
ça peut aller de l'achat de lunettes
mais aussi hélas à des enfants qui
dorment dans leur voiture qui dorment
dans un petit
dix mètres carrés encore là je suis
généreuse et c'est à ça que doit servir
le p r us sans merci merci ma parole est
maintenant président jacques legendre
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole monsieur
le président merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la dernière enquête pilotée par l' ocde
pisa programme international pour le
suivi des acquis des élèves évalue et
compare les connaissances des élèves de
15 ans dans trois domaines la lecture
des matériels la lecture les
mathématiques et la culture scientifique
cette enquête montre le poids de
l'origine sociale dans les inégalités
scolaires en france alors que notre pays
était dans la moyenne en 2000 en dix ans
il ya eu un creusement des inégalités
scolaires d'origine sociale
deux exemples sont frappants en france à
lycéens de milieux défavorisés a deux
fois moins de chances d'entrer
d'enseignement supérieur que s'il avait
grandi en espagne ou en irlande dans
notre pays un lycéen à 83 fois plus de
risque d'être en échec à 15 ans s'il est
issu d'un milieu social défavorisé
alors que la moyenne de l'oci devait
être trois fois un autre enseignement
fort de cette enquête est que
l'efficacité ne se mesure pas seulement
au niveau de la dépense publique études
montrent que certains pays de l' ocde
qui dépensent moins que la france sont
mieux classés pologne singapour corée du
sud par exemple
l'enjeu est donc de dépenser mieux de
redéployer les moyens en fonction des
priorités des besoins devront déjà
avancer dans cette voie comme
l'illustrent notamment deux types de
mesures mises en place des programmes du
primaire recentrer sur les fondamentaux
que sont la lecture et l'écriture et
instauration d'un véritable dispositif
d'accompagnement éducatif comprenant
l'aide personnalisée l'accompagnement
personnalisé
le tutorat l'internât d'excellence ces
mesures que nous soutenons met en
lumière l'objectif poursuivi par le
gouvernement ces dernières années
limiter le plus possible le nombre
d'élèves en difficulté mais cela ne
saurait suffire et notre système
éducatif doit encore évoluer
pouvez vous nous préciser monsieur le
ministre les mesures que le gouvernement
envisage
notamment en matière d'autonomie de
décision des établissements scolaires
pour renforcer notre efficacité dans le
domaine de l'éducation je vous remercie
pour répondre de président le jean luc
chatel ministre de l'éducation nationale
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président le gendre vous
avez rappelé les résultats de l'enquêté
pisa qui sont très intéressants parce
qu'ils nous permettent de comparer notre
système éducatif avec près de 64 pays
membres de l ocde où au delà et ils
montrent que notre pays se situe à la
fin du premier tiers de l'ensemble du
panel qui a été évalué nous sommes dans
la moyenne des pays de l'osce et des
oeufs au niveau des acquis aussi bien en
français que en mathématiques mais
surtout ces tests pisa nous renseigne
sur deux faiblesses de notre système
éducatif
d'abord la france reste le pays du grand
écart c'est à dire que nous avons un
niveau un nombre d'élèves qui acceptent
à l'excellence à l'élite qui est trop
réduit alors que nous avons un nombre
d'élèves en grande difficulté qui a
plutôt tendance à augmenter
et puis deuxièmement nous savons que
nous avons du mal à lutter dans le
système éducatif français contre les
déterminismes sociaux et c'est le cas
d'ailleurs dans tous les grands pays
développés mais encore plus le cas en
france où nous avons du mal à lutter
contre les inégalités sociales alors que
faire par rapport à cela
je pense que la politique vous avez
évoqué monsieur legendre et que nous
menons va dans la bonne direction non
pas parce que c'est la nôtre mais c'est
parce que c'est elle qui a été menée par
tous les pays qui obtiennent de
meilleurs résultats que nous dans ces
enquêtes pisa une politique est basée
sur la personnalisation de
l'enseignement si on veut
après le défi de la massification de la
quantité qui a été celui des années de
70 à 90 dans le système éducatif
français
si on veut réussir le défi de la qualité
c'est à dire faire en sorte qu'ils aient
bien une solution pour chacun à la fin
de l'école nous devons tout lallaing
tout au long de la scolarité organiser
des temps de différenciation c'est à
dire faire plus pour les élèves qui ont
plus de difficultés c'est à dire être
capable d'accompagner individuellement
les élèves comme par exemple les
décrocheurs scolaires ce que nous
faisons avec les plateformes de
décrocheurs comme par exemple l'aide
personnalisée dès le primaire pour
détecter les difficultés de lecture
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
ou comme par exemple le travail que nous
menons sur les enfants handicapés nous
accueillons beaucoup plus d'enfants
handicapés aujourd'hui qu'il ya cinq ans
dans le système éducatif et puis nous
avons un autre levier a activé que vous
avez évoqué c'est faire davantage
confiance aux acteurs locaux délégué
transférer des compétences vers les
établissements scolaires les chefs
d'établissements le vert les professeurs
c'est le sens de l'autonomie que nous
mettons en marche progressivement dans
le système éducatif plus de
personnalisation plus d'autonomie
c'est l'esprit de la politique que nous
menons je pense que c'est la meilleure
réponse à ces tests pisa le président le
jambes très brièvement parce que le
ministre nous a apporté beaucoup
d'éclairage accent sur les décrocheurs
ces problèmes nous préoccupe les revues
dans d'autres pays ma mission ma
commission s'est rendue récemment au
canada il ya vu ce qui se faisait en
ontario au canada pour les élèves
décrocheurs
nous pensons que nous avons là des
exemples à prendre il vaut mieux
rattraper les élèves menacé de
décrochage quand ils sont encore à
l'école que de mettre en place des
systèmes de rattrapage plus coûteux
ensuite est moins efficace
priorité à l'école merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue yannick bodin
pour le groupe socialiste devait la
parole dans leurs collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
j'y reviens les conclusions de l'étude
pisa 2009 sont alarmantes est
révélatrice de l'échec des politiques
éducatives de la france selon cette
étude la proportion des élèves les moins
performants en compréhension de l'écrit
est passée de 15 à 20 % loin d'avoir
tiré les leçons du classement moyen de
2003 le gouvernement a laissé se
dégrader la qualité de notre
enseignement et quelques mesures
annoncées limitée à quelques
expérimentations d'ailleurs n'y ont rien
changé le rapport pisa est clair le
système éducatif français du lumière peu
reluisante en prenant en compte
iccat heures divers indicateurs comme la
profession des parents leur formation le
long de deux livres à la maison ou
encore la langue parlée
ce rapport démontre qu'en france plus
que dans lequel notre pays de l' ocde
il est beaucoup plus difficile pour les
jeunes issus de milieux défavorisés de
réussir à l'école avec une vulnérabilité
particulièrement marquée pour les jeunes
de la première génération immigrés
autrement dit en france l'origine
sociale et familiale est un facteur
déterminant pour réussir à l'école
nous sommes le champion des inégalités
en matière d'éducation et ça c'est
inacceptable
dans le même temps le groupe des
meilleurs élèves lui est passé de 2 de
8,5 à 9,6 en lecture alors que cette
progression devrait nous réjouir ces
chiffres constituent une autre source
d'inquiétude car ils montrent que les
écarts se creusent entre les élèves au
sein de notre système le système
français actuel est conçu pour les
élites
la politique la plus récente celle de la
carte scolaire ou des lycées
d'excellence par exemple à la prétention
de permettre l'émergence et
l'élargissement de ses élites
la tension est certes bonne non quand
faudra-t-il que dans le même temps la
grande masse ne soit pas abandonnée à
son sort pourtant un des enseignements
fondamentaux du rapport pisa nous
montrent que vrai en faveur à favoriser
l'excellence coupure n'a rien de
contradictoire avec le fait de rehausser
le niveau de compétences des élèves peu
performant
au vu de ces constats quelles mesures
allez vous prendre monsieur le ministre
pour inverser la tendance de
l'aggravation des inégalités dans les
écoles de notre pays et éviter que lors
de la prochaine enquête pisa en 2012
la france ne recule une nouvelle fois
dans le classement international pour
vous répondre la parole est au ministre
de l'éducation nationale monsieur dit
choqué merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bodin vous avez
utilisé un ton nom polémique pour votre
question donc je vous répondrais sur le
même ton mais vous avez fait référence à
l'action du gouvernement par rapport à
la politique éducative juste une
remarque monsieur gaudin les élèves qui
ont été évalués par le test pisa de 2009
il avait 15 ans en 2009 ils sont entrés
dans le système éducatif en 1997 donc ce
sont les enfants des réformes qui ont
été menés à la fin des années 80 et au
début des années 90 dans le système
éducatif
n'y voyez pas malice de ma part c'est
simplement un recul une analyse une
analyse qui permet de mieux appréhender
l'impact des politiques éducatives et de
mesurer leurs résultats alors monsieur
le sénateur je note comme vous les
carences de notre système éducatif et
nous cherchons à y remédier c'est par
exemple pour cette raison que nous avons
décidé de mettre en place des internats
d'excellence
c'est quoi les internats d'excellence
c'est l'idée de permettre à des élèves
issus de milieux défavorisés dont on
sait que s'ils ne sont pas pris en
charge davantage par le système éducatif
accompagné aussi bien sur le plan
éducatif que sur le plan culturel et
bien ces élèves là on sait très bien
qu'ils ne réussiront pas et bien 4000
élèves actuellement bénéficient de ce
nouveau dispositif
c'est un vrai progrès en matière
d'égalité des chances ensuite monsieur
le sénateur vous me permettrez de
répondre sur l'opposition vous essayez
de pot de fer entre l'élite saint et les
élèves en grande difficulté
monsieur le sénateur moi je pense que
nous devons relever le niveau de
l'ensemble de nos élèves nous avons
besoin d'une élite dans notre pays et
j'observe que dans un pays comme la
finlande
on a 14 à 15 % d'une classe d'âge qui
est considéré comme faisant partie de
l'élite
là où en france on est à moins de 10%
donc nous avons aussi en france besoin
de jeunes plus qualifiés qui vont vers
l'excellence et l'école de la république
c'est aussi l'école kipp est capable de
mener les élèves méritants le plus loin
possible et en même temps nous avons
besoin de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
moins d'élèves qui quittent le système
éducatif sans qualification avec un
accompagnement personnalisé plus
important et ça c'est l'idée de toute la
politique que nous menons de
personnalisation tout au long de la
scolarité est personnalisée
accompagnement éducatif accompagnement
personnalisé au lycée
vous voyez telle est la politique que
nous voulons mener pour inverser cette
tendance qui est une tendance
structurelle qui remonte à plusieurs
années mais
si monsieur bonhomme oui monsieur le
ministre j'ai cru à l'instant que vous
alliez me reprocher à charlemagne dans
le avant pas pensé plus tôt a inventé
l'école
ceci étant dit vous prenez je prendre un
seul exemple pour répondre les internats
d'excellence
imaginons et je veux faire ce rêve que
les internats d'excellence soit
effectivement une solution pour les
élèves qui sont particulièrement
difficulté y compris sur le plan social
mais êtes vous aujourd'hui en mesure
monsieur le ministre de dire qu'il y
aura autant d'internats d'excellence en
france qui lie à d'élèves en difficulté
y compris sur le plan social
ça n'est pas en créant une dizaine
d'établissements que vous réglerait le
problème
il en faut quelques centaines en france
et ça pouvait vous aujourd'hui dans les
contraintes budgétaires que vous nous
expliquer assez souvent faire en sorte
qu' il y ait une réponse pour tout le
monde
en conclusion pour l'instant les
internats d'excellence c'est de
l'affichage et vous avez à la porte de
ces internats des centaines de milliers
d'élèves qui attendent
et ça ça n'est pas tolérable la parole
est maintenant notre collègue me groupe
si morin pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen sénateurs du parti
gauche avaient la parole mme asher cohen
président monsieur le ministre je
souhaite vous interroger sur le
dispositif clair et sur le démantèlement
de l'éducation prioritaire qu'il induit
de fait je voudrais d'abord vous citez
le dispositif clair s'il réussit si
l'expérimentation fonctionne a pour
objectif d'être étendue et de remplacer
les dispositifs d'éducation prioritaire
qui existe aujourd'hui
marseille le 25 juin dernier puis ce
programme est une expérimentation qui
n'a pas a priori vocation à se
substituer à tout
l'éducation prioritaire nous adresserons
le bilan nous l'évaluerons et nous
réfléchirons à la façon de coordonner
les différents dispositifs au sénat le
26 octobre dernier
depuis votre ministère a annoncé
l'extension en septembre du programme
clair qui absorberait ainsi la quasi
totalité des réseaux ambition réussite
sur quelle base quel bilan quel
évaluation quatre mois seulement
d'expérimentation en quoi claire est il
plus probant que les dispositifs
existants leur nature est très
différente claire est un programme de
lutte contre la violence scolaire
une différence de taille avec
l'éducation prioritaire qui avant tout
un dispositif de lutte contre les
inégalités sociales et territoriales en
matière éducative avec l'air plus de
notion de zone ni de réseau c'est la
logique d'établissement qui l'emportent
pas étonnant pour qui promotionne
l'autonomie des établissements
claire se caractériserait par son
innovation
mais l'innovation pédagogique a toujours
été le maître mot de l'éducation
prioritaire
dans ce domaine la circulaire claire du
7 juillet ne propose d'ailleurs rien de
nouveau nous la vraie innovation de
claire réside dans la mort prudent il
est vrai le sujet étant sensible de la
généralisation des postes à profil pour
à terme imposer la libéralisation du
recrutement des enseignants
alors que les acteurs de l'éducation
prioritaire s'accordent pour en réclamer
la relance vous l'atomiser monsieur le
ministre que deviendront les réseaux de
réussite scolaire et les milliers
d'élèves qu'ils accueillent pour vous
répondre la parole était monsieur luc
chatel ministre de l'éducation nationale
d'abord madame le sénateur monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je veux vous rappeler que l'éducation
nationale investit chaque année plus
d'un milliard d'euros dans l'éducation
prioritaire c'est donc un engagement
significatif qui fait partie des
politiques que nous menons et ce système
cette politique d'éducation prioritaire
avait besoin de toilettage
d'harmonisation de coordination
je rappelle que nous avons aujourd'hui
de mémoire plus de 13 dispositif qui se
superposent
c'est le résultat d'empilement de
politique menée depuis le début des
années 80 le millefeuille de qui s'est
superposée des différentes organisations
c'est un constat madame c'est pas une
critique
on a le droit d'avoir des idées des
propositions simplement mettez vous à la
place d'enseignants qui voit se
superposer des politiques sans véritable
cohérence alors qu'eux ils ont besoin de
mobiliser leurs moyens et de concentrer
leurs énergies pour faire réussir leurs
élèves
donc oui nous avons une conviction
madame c'est que c'est en donnant
davantage de moyens et en faisant
davantage confiance aux acteurs locaux
aux établissements aux professeurs aux
chefs d'établissement qu'on obtient de
meilleurs résultats dans des
établissements qui ont plus de
difficultés qui accueille davantage
d'élèves issus de familles défavorisées
et qu'ils peuvent rencontrer des
problèmes en matière de violence et
d'ailleurs ça corrobore un certain
nombre d'études internationales et ça a
était issue des états généraux sur la
sécurité à l'école que nous avons
organisée au mois d'avril dernier
donc nous avons expérimenté le
dispositif clair dans 105 collèges
aujourd'hui qui permet une autonomie à
la fois pédagogique une autonomie en
matière de recrutement c'est une vraie
nouveauté qu'un chefs d'établissements
puissent partager un projet pédagogique
avec son équipe et donc recruté en
conséquence des enseignants qui
partagent ce projet pédagogique et
dispositif innovant parce que les
professeurs qui s'engagent s'engageront
pour cinq années avec une volonté donc
de participer sur la durée à un tel
projet nous avons besoin de stabilité
danser les abysses mans et nous avons
besoin également de rémunérer davantage
de revaloriser les étudiants les
enseignants qui font ce choix de
s'engager dans des établissements plus
difficile pendant plusieurs années
c'est donc tout l'esprit de ce programme
clair et l'idée c'est que les
dispositifs rares les collèges rar
réseaux ambition réussite
évocation je dis bien et vocation à
devenir clair progressivement je ne dis
pas que tous les collèges claire
passeront rares à la rentrée je vis les
locations à le devenir dans un souci de
clarification et de simplification d'un
vingtième rang grièvement
merci toilettage monsieur le ministre on
sait ce que ça veut dire en langage rgpp
moi je vais vous donner un exemple dans
les hauts-de-seine sur 24 collèges en
réseau réussite scolaire 3 seulement
seraient préservés c'est ça votre
politique
quid également de la cohérence avec la
politique de la ville la révision de la
carte des aides devaient se faire on
s'en souvient en lien l'excellent des us
mais cette dernière pourrait
n'intervenir qu'en 2014 date de
prolongation des contrats urbains de
cohésion sociale
bien sûr d'ici là la réforme des
collectivités territoriales sera entré
en vigueur cette politique éducative
n'est pas la bonne monsieur ministre
carla elle abandonne un objectif
fondamental celui de la mixité sociale
pour lui préférer une mixité des élites
investissant des moyens sur quelques
bons parmi les plus défavorisés je vous
le dis très sincèrement ces choix ne
permettront pas d'inverser le creusement
des inégalités scolaires en france où
l'impact de l'environnement
socio-économique c'est ce que di pisa
sur la réussite des élèves est
particulièrement élevé
pire je crois il les accentueront la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
jacqueline gourault pour le groupe de
l'union centriste le b la parole
monsieur le ministre je ne doute pas que
vous estimiez que dans notre démocratie
la reconnaissance des talents et des
mérites ne devrait pas dépendre de
l'hérédité sociales et des hasards de la
naissance
et pourtant jamais depuis le début de la
massification scolaire comme vous avez
dit tout à l'heure qui a ouvert les
études longues aux plus grands n'ont
jamais notre école n'a été aussi inégal
deux exemples très rapidement tirer des
statistiques de votre ministère 79 100
des élèves provenant des catégories
sociales favorisées ont obtenu un bac
général contre seulement 18 % des élèves
d'origine défavorisée 55 % des
bacheliers qui entrent dans les classes
préparatoires aux grandes écoles ont un
père cadres chefs d'entreprise
professeurs ou membre d'une profession
libérale contre cinq pour cent des
enfants d'ouvriers et ligali l'inégalité
c'est aussi l'inégalité
je vais pas reprendre tous les chiffres
pisa qu'ont donné mes collègues
des milliers d'enfants qui n'ont pas les
éléments fondamentaux du savoir la
lecture l'écriture et le calcul vous
savez bien monsieur me disent que le nom
d'élèves faible en compréhension de ces
matières de base a augmenté de façon
spectaculaire d'une étude à l'autre de
pisa et notamment le nombre de ces
élèves parmi les plus pauvres
socialement donc on court vers une école
à deux vitesses
monsieur le ministre je suis de celles
qui pensent qui a deux choses
fondamentales le nombre d'enseignants et
la formation des enseignants
et là il s'agit pas de deux vous accusé
de quoi que ce soit chaque gouvernement
à lui ses responsabilités mais là ce
sont deux questions précises c'est la
suppression des postes à la rentrée et
la suppression de la formation des
maîtres
même si j'ai entendu monsieur le
ministre je vous la corde le président
de la république dire qu'ils allaient
réouvrir ce chantier je crois qu'il
aurait mieux fait de ne pas le fermer
donc monsieur le ministre quand allez
vous nous donner des objectifs précis et
simple concerter avec les acteurs de
l'éducation et préparer l'école de
demain merci pour vous répondre la
parole est un monsieur luc chatel
ministre de l'éducation nationale
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame le sénateur gouraud vous avez
raison de vous indignés contre le nombre
d'élèves qui quittent le système
éducatif sans qualification qui
maîtrisent mal les fondamentaux
je me permets simplement d'attirer
l'attention de la haute assemblée sur le
fait que ce nombre n'a jamais été aussi
peu élevé notre système éducatif et que
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
quelle était la situation dans notre
système éducatif avant le collège unique
quelle était la situation a le vent
qu'il y ait des bacs professionnels qui
permettent une incertaine inventé par
jean pierre chevènement grandes avancées
qui ont permis une insertion
professionnelle grâce à l'éducation
nationale donc il faut aussi regarder
les résultats sur une longue durée à
leurs malades gros vous avez raison
de vous indignés contre le fait que 20 %
d'élèves qui ne maîtrisent
insuffisamment les fondamentaux en
sortant du primaire c'est trop important
et nous devons nous mobiliser face à
cela et bien c'est précisément ce que
nous avons fait j'ai décidé d'engager un
plan de lutte contre l'illettrisme qui
prévoit de travailler dès la classe
maternelle sur la question du
vocabulaire l'apprentissage des mots le
par coeur parce que la vraie inégalité
sociale madame gouro c'est qu'un élève
qui est issu d'un milieu favorisé il va
maîtriser 600 ou 700 morts entre en
cours préparatoire
là où l'élève qui sort d'un milieu
défavorisé
il va maîtriser 150 ou 200 mo eh bien on
sait que ce deuxième élève il a beaucoup
moins de chance apprendre à lire
correctement que le premier donc le rôle
de l'école c'est d'inverser cette
tendance est donc d'être capable dé la
classe maternelle mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une mobilisation autour de la lutte
contre l'illettrisme et c'est ce que
nous avons engagé
enfin vous vous inquiétez du nombre de
professeurs madame le sénateur
je veux juste vous rassurer sur le fait
qu' il y aura à la rentrée 2011 plus de
professeurs dans le système éducatif
qu'à la fin des aides au début des
années 90 alors qu'il ya moins d'élèves
dans le système éducatif a parlé
maintenant madame gouraud je pense qu'on
a un problème de statistiques mais ça
n'est pas grave
monsieur mini je vais vous dire quelque
chose ne le prenez pas mal hein ne le
prenez pas comme une attaque ne le
prenez pas je dis ça à un bon monsieur
le ministre monsieur le ministre je vais
vous dire un truc vous avez parlé de
l'anglais à trois ans et à quelques il
ya deux ou trois semaines
vous avez parlé d'un seul enseignant
pour les sciences physiques la chimie
les sciences de la vie et la technologie
j'entends bien mais c'est comment dire
c'est digne c'est presque des niches je
dirai ce que les français attendent et
prenez le vraiment avec positivement ce
que les français attendent c'est que
leurs enfants qui sont dans l'école de
la république réussissent comme c'était
le cas sous la 3ème et la 4ème
république
je ne crois pas je ne vois pas pourquoi
on ne serait pas capable de le faire
aujourd'hui pour que notre pays
non mais les chances j'entends monsieur
le ministre que vous me dites mais pour
que notre pays est une chance de devenir
dans l'avenir une nation de recherche
une dation avec des têtes bien faites
une nation je dirais qu'ils préparent
notre jeunesse à l'avenir et la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue alain
dufaut pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
depuis la rentrée scolaire 2007
l'assouplissement de la carte scolaire
pour ne pas dire une suppression a eu un
effet pervers dans les établissements
réputés difficiles en particulier en
zone d'éducation prioritaire et bien
évidemment dans les collèges ambition
réussite dans ces secteurs on assiste en
effet à ce que j'ai appelé un écrémage
des meilleurs élèves qui partent dans
d'autres établissements
quand ce n'est pas dans l'enseignement
privé est bien évidemment une
accentuation de la ghettoïsation des
collèges ou lycées des quartiers
défavorisés
la chambre général des comptes a
d'ailleurs dénoncé un rapport en mai
2010 le risque de ces ghettos scolaires
en ce qui me concerne j'ai eu le triste
privilège d'être le conseiller général
d'un canton où le premier collèges du
réseau ambition réussite a été fermé sur
les 254 que compte le réseau
il s'agit du collège paul giéra dans le
quartier moncada union et même s'il faut
chercher les vraies motivations de cette
fermeture dans les justifications
politico-financières il empêche que
c'est en raison de l'assouplissement de
la carte scolaire que le conseil général
de vaucluse a pris la décision de le
fermer et bien après une année
d'expérience de redéploiement de ses
élèves dans deux des collèges du centre
ville
le bilan éducatif et social est un
véritable fiasco
l'hétérogénéité des classes rendent la
tâche des équipes des enseignants
complètement insurmontable
l'absence de proximité de
l'établissement et du quartier ne cesse
faire croître l'absentéisme enfin les
moyens en diminution ajoute encore la
difficulté des enquêtes des enseignants
non préparés à ce public d'élèves plus
d'élèves par classe 26 au lieu de 20 ans
faisait pas moins de cpe pas de
passerelle avec 17 pas que d'école
ouverte etc
alors j'ai attiré en entreprise de
latence
on est responsable éducation nationale
sur ce sujet y compris vous monsieur le
ministre j'ai même déposé une
proposition de loi le 1er septembre 2009
pour essayer de provoquer de mixité à
l'envers dans ce si l'établissement
mais le tout est restée sans suite
pourriez-vous munich et donc quelles
sont les pistes mises en place par
l'éducation nationale qui peuvent
influer de façon optimale sur l'air
d'attraction de ces établissements qu'il
s'agisse de la différenciation de
l'offre de formation ou bien sur des
modalités d'affectation des élèves pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur
luc chatel ministre de l'éducation
nationale lui avait là bas si monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur du faux d'abord si
la carte sociale
la carte scolaire a voulu être
assouplies par le président de la
république c'est parce que monsieur du
faux j'ai le sentiment et je pense
qu'elle est partagée sur beaucoup de
banc dans votre assemblée que le système
précédent était absolument désastreux et
qui l'a conduit à une ghettoïsation que
vous dénoncez aujourd'hui vous mêmes
nous avons assoupli le système et non
pas supprimer le système ce qui a
d'ailleurs permis un certain nombre
d'élèves enfants de boursiers d'élèves
issus de milieux défavorisés d'élèves
enfants handicapés de bénéficier de
dérogations alors que ce n'était pas le
cas précédemment et je veux monsieur le
sénateur rebondir sur l'exemple que vous
avez cités dans votre département
d'abord l'éducation nationale ne ferme
pas de collège sans l'avis de l'autorité
organisatrice départemental à savoir le
conseil général dont vous êtes membre
monsieur le sénateur et il y a eu un
travail de concertation entre
l'inspection d'académie et le conseil
général de votre département pour
réorganiser la carte scolaire les deux
collèges d'accueil mistral et vernet qui
ont accueilli les élèves du l'ex-collège
gerra ont aujourd'hui un nombre moyen
d'élèves par division qui est analogue à
celui de l'éducation prioritaire
les moyens réseau ambition réussite du
collège giera ont été intégralement
redistribuée au collège d'accueil et ils
ont même été majorée monsieur le
sénateur puisque un poste supplémentaire
de cpe a été attribué au collège mistral
les neuf assistants d'éducation qui
existait dans le collège giera ont été
transférés dans les deux collèges donc
ce sont des moyens supplémentaires et le
transfert de ses élèves monsieur le
sénateur il faut le reconnaître a été
avec le recul bénéfique sans que
l'attractivité des établissements
d'accueil en pâtissent puisque sur
l'ensemble des collèges du vaucluse
le collège vernet occupe la quatrième
place en matière d'attractivité et le
collège mistral la 16e et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'absentéisme son
déguisement abc d'envoyer monsieur le
sénateur je sais que ce sont décisions
difficiles pour des élus mais en même
temps c'est important de regarder
comment répartir les moyens sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour qu'à la
fin
le système public de l'éducation
nationale soient plus performants et
c'est ce que nous faisons au quotidien
avec les élus locaux
monsieur du faux monsieur le ministre il
se trouve que les trois établissements
qu'on avait cité y compris de 200 truies
sont en manque en temps et que je
participe à tous les conseils
d'administration je sais très bien que
la situation n'est pas aussi idyllique
que ce qu'on vous l'a décrit à partir de
l'inspection d'académie du vaucluse
alors moi ce que je voudrais vous dire
très simplement
le but ce n'est pas de remettre en cause
l'assouplissement de la carte scolaire
c'est d'essayer de trouver des solutions
efficaces pour éviter que dans les
quartiers difficiles en ambition
réussite et en zep la ghettoïsation
augmente
bon c'est ça la vérité alors si on peut
favoriser des mixités à l'envers comme
jeux proposés dans ma proposition de loi
je crois que c'est une bonne solution
moi je considère gras mixité ne se
décrète pas mais qu'il faut l'a
favorisée par les moyens adaptés
suite
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
notre collègue madame françoise cartron
pour le groupe socialiste de la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
en premier lieu je souhaiterais attirer
votre attention sur la sixième enquête
quadrillé nal réalisée par
l'observatoire de la vie étudiante
les résultats publiés en ce début
d'année sont alarmants ainsi les
étudiants issus des classes populaires
sont moins nombreux qu il y a quatre ans
à suivre des études supérieures de 35 %
en 2006 leur part est descendu à 31% en
2010 malgré ces conclusions inquiétantes
rien n'est fait pour conforter notre
système éducatif bien au contraire
en effet ni le rapport la cour des
comptes publié en 2010 ni les résultats
de l'enquêté pisa n'auront eu d'effets
sur votre politique qui se borne à
comptabiliser la part croissante
d'élèves en échec scolaire le plus
souvent issus de milieux défavorisés
a contrario vous usez et abusez d'une
rhétorique celle de l'excellence
l'objectif de 30% de boursiers en
classes préparatoires très bien si ce
n'est qu'un enfant d'ouvrier sur deux ne
décroche pas le bac
une évaluation cm2 pour lutter contre
l'échec scolaire pourquoi pas mais dans
le même temps les rased sont supprimées
et les maîtres absents non remplacés
vous agissez comme un tamis éducatif qui
sélectionne les meilleurs et ne
cherchait jamais intervenir en amont
ainsi le recul de la scolarisation entre
2 et 3 ans qui est passée de 35 % à 12 %
et tout particulièrement dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire la suppression
de la carte scolaire dont on vient de
parler augmentant la ghettoïsation de
certains établissements jouent en
défaveur des plus fragiles au delà de
l'étranglement budgétaire qui étouffe
les équipes sur le terrain
vous vous êtes également attaqué la
formation des enseignants tous les pays
en tête dans les classements
internationaux ont investi massivement
dans ces formations
la mastérisation mise en place
prévention abouti un véritable gâchis
alors au travers des prises des propos
de monsieur le président la république
monsieur le ministre
qu'entendez vous par éléments de la
formation à revoir car derrière si le
femise ne se trouve la réalité du
terrain et sans vous perdre dans un
style amphigourique une réponse claire
et précise nous permettrait de nous
éclairer tous le ministre de l'éducation
nationale aux réponses de la parole
madame le sénateur mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le président je
crois que deux minutes trente pour
répondre à votre question soit un petit
peu court mais je vais tâcher de vous
apporter quelques éclaircissements
nous avons décidé de nous attaquer aux
inégalités sociales avec ma collègue
valérie pécresse le président de la
république avait fixé un objectif 30% de
boursiers
tu as préparatoires nous avons dépassé
cet objectif avant l'échéance qui
avaient été fixés donc c'est un signal
très fort que nous envoyons à des élèves
issus de milieux modestes mais qui
doivent réussir grâce à l'école de la
république dans la réforme du lycée que
nous avons engagées depuis la dernière
rentrée
nous avons décidé d'accompagner
davantage les élèves dans leur choix
d'orientation
vous évoquez les inégalités sociales et
vous avez raison mais qu'est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui deux plus forts comme
inégalités sociales que l'accompagnement
en matière d'orientation entre un élève
qui va être parce qu'il est issu d'un
milieu qui connaît l'école le système
éducatif est un enfant issu d'un milieu
familial peut être des structures et
éloigné de l'école il y a une vraie
inégalité y en a un qui va se voir
décrypter le monde de l'école et qui va
éviter parfois les pièges la complexité
du système et il va trouver sa voie et
l'autre qui sera incapable s'orienter de
manière personnelle donc nous avons
décidé d'accompagner beaucoup plus les
élèves en matière d'orientation une
orientation progressive une orientation
choisie qui va se faire tout au long de
la scolarité du lycée avec des
changements de trajectoires possibles
avec des passerelles avec des remises à
niveau des stages de remise à niveau
pour les élèves et avec l'idée d'un
tutorat en matière d'orientation qui est
pratiqué par les professeurs vous avez
d'un côté
l'accompagnement technique par les
conseillers d'orientation et puis de
l'autre qui connaît le mieux les élèves
en dehors des parents eh bien ce sont
les professeurs est donc dorénavant ils
peuvent accompagner les élèves dans ce
domaine donc vous voyez je pense que
c'est en ayant un meilleur
accompagnement le plus tôt possible de
ces élèves qui peuvent avoir du talent
qui peuvent avoir du mérite mais qu'on
doit détecter les porter vers la
réussite
c'est comme cela que nous avons décidé
de mobiliser notre système éducatif
mille excuses monsieur ministre mais
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
la question portait sur la formation des
maîtres puisque dans toutes les enquêtes
pisa qui montre les pays en tête lorsque
nous analysons pourquoi l'arrêt il y à
une telle réussite c'est lié à
l'investissement massif qui a été fait
dans la formation des enseignants
or malheureusement nous sommes allés à
contrario dans cette dans cet objectif
est aujourd'hui vous le constatez la
mastérisation est un échec
donc la question je voulais vous poser
c'est quel remède
allez-vous apporter pour la prochaine
rentrée afin que l'on n'est pas ces
jeunes étudiants qui sortent tous frais
moulu des universités et qui découvre
une classe en même temps que des élèves
et en même temps que toute la difficulté
du métier d'enseignant
merci la parole et à notre collègue
philippe darniche pour la réunion des
sénateurs ne figureront sur la liste
aucun gros vous avez la parole du
collectif seul président michel ministre
combattre les inégalités sociales et la
vocation même de l'école d'art et public
et pourtant malgré les différentes
réformes menées depuis 40 ans pour y
parvenir la mise en place du collège
unique en 75 ou la loi d'orientation
scolaire en 89 et bien d'autres depuis
elle s'aggrave ces inégalités
la massification de l'enseignement n'a
pas tenu ses promesses et la prétention
de vouloir faire de l'enfant l'acteur de
son propre apprentissage a échoué
les statistiques entretiennent pourtant
la confusion et le doute sur la nature
des problèmes
la massification de l'accès au bac et à
l'enseignement supérieur ne serait-elle
pas la preuve que l'égalité des chances
est renforcée en réalité il n'en est
rien et ce sont des enfants des milieux
les plus favorisés qui accapare l'accès
aux filières les plus prestigieuses de
l'éducation des conséquences de cette
politique se lisent dans les rapports
d'éducation nationale cent soixante
mille jeunes quittent chaque année le
système scolaire sans qualification
25 % des écoliers ont des acquis
fragiles en français et en mathématiques
15 % connaissent des difficultés sévères
et très sévère à l'issue du primaire la
france a beau abriter certains de ses
meilleurs des meilleurs mathématiciens
du monde
elle souffre toujours du niveau très
décevante ces élèves en algèbre
géométrie
c'est triste constate ainsi dans des
comparaisons internationales
je n'hésiterai pas nombre de mes
collègues qui ont fait allusion mais
tout montre que le niveau baisse chez
nous régulièrement les premiers affectés
par cette désillusion sur les enfants
des milieux modestes qui se sont égarés
garer sans information ni préparation
adéquate dans des filières non sélective
et sans débouchés leurs parents étaient
pourtant fière d'avoir un premier
bachelier puis un licencié dans la
famille et pourtant
l'ascenseur social n'est pas au rendez
vous alors monsieur le ministre comment
parvenir à lutter contre les inégalités
sociales dans le système scolaire sans
restaurer la transmission des savoirs
fondeur fondamentaux par des méthodes
qui ont fait leurs preuves
la volonté d'ouvrir nos écoliers très
jeune à des connaissances élargie est
certes la pelure mais ne s'était pas
heurter à l'acquisition des fondamentaux
maîtrise la lecture de l'écriture et du
calcul préparant ainsi nos enfants aux
études secondaires puis supérieur quand
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur
luc chatel ministre de l'éducation
nationale
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je pense que vous avez raison
et pendant de nombreuses années à la
suite d'une période liées à mai 68 sans
doute nous avons oublié dans notre
système éducatif que enseigner s'était
d'abord transmettre des savoirs et
l'apogée ayant été
la loi jospin de 1989 qui place l enfant
au coeur du système
oubliant qu'ils étaient sans doute le
maître et l'élève
eh bien monsieur le sénateur moi je
crois un système éducatif qui mise sur
la transmission des savoirs qui rappelle
que éduquer c'est transmettre un certain
nombre de valeurs s'est préparé des
citoyens et nous avons décidé de
remettre en place un certain nombre de
fondamentaux
mon prédécesseur xavier darcos a mis en
place une réforme du primaire qui est
basée sur des programmes à base de
fondamentaux
j'ai moi même décidé de réinstaurer
systématiquement le calcul mental pour
que dès le plus jeune âge
on travaille sur les mathématiques on
fasse travailler la mémoire pour
l'agilité d'esprit et faire en sorte que
les élèves dès le plus jeune âge soient
préparés à cela nous avons également
dans le domaine de la lecture décidé de
revenir à des méthodes de lecture qui
permettent un apprentissage meilleurs
dont vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur
nous avons décidé de recourir à ces
méthodes fondamentales qui ont fait
leurs fruits parce que l'on doit pas
oublier que éduquer c'est d'abord
transmettre le savoir les ché merci
merci monsieur le ministre des
informations de vous donner cependant je
voudrais je voudrais simplement rajouté
que il nous faut très souvent faire
appel à des bénévoles pour aider les
enfants le soir à la sortie de l'école
qui ne peuvent pas trouver chez eux un
soutien supplémentaire pour compléter le
travail qui est fait par les maîtres ce
qui nous pose quand même quelques
problèmes parce que autant ce dispositif
est utile il est difficile à mettre en
place mais autant je crois que c'est à
notre école de la république de le
mettre en place totalement merci merci
mon cher collègue mes chers collègues je
vais maintenant suspende la séance et
sera reprise à 18h10 pour la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale en natif à
l'immigration à l'intégration et à la
nationalité
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
merci
7 6 ans se dit ventes de questions
cribles la séance est suspendue
voilà pour cette séance de questions
cribles thématiques dans quelques
instants les sénateurs vont examiner le
projet de loi sur l'immigration je vous
retrouve dans une dizaine de minutes
avec françois noël buffet rapporteur ump
de ce texte au sénat à tout à l'heure